Manifestationですね
現象化するんです その場面を
それでもうずっと心がそればっかし考えたりする
だから悪いことを思い浮かぶか
いいことを思い浮かぶかっていうことは
どうそれまた言いにくいことでわからないことで不確定である
で  三十五番目に書いているのはそのことなんですね
あるいはまたかの結晶を生じさせる業が新たにその業をなすかのように
どうやって読むんです
これは ん？あ よそって慰問に達すると
で とにかくこの まあ現代の言葉で言えば
あの 明確に自分に心に現れることなんですね
再現する その出来事 こっちこの夢のようにとか何て書いてますけど
まあ夢のようじゃないんです
全く まあリアルに この方が一番リアルなんです
例えば 今私が何か見ていると直接見えないんです
体を通して見なくちゃいけないんです
で あの誰かの音楽家がね
耳が聞こえなくて 誰でしたっけ？あ
ベートーベン それで直接聞こえないんですね
直接聞こえないんだから
何か道具を使って 杖でも何とかでも使って
そこから伝わってくる波動で
あ こういう音だろうと感じなくちゃいけない
それで彼が耳が遠くなった時から
前と同じく美しい音楽を聴いたかというと
全くそうじゃないんです
天才でしたから まあおそらくそういう音でしょうと
おそらくこういうことだろうと
まあ頭で想像するしかない
我々の普通の知識っていうのは
知恵っていうのは そういうふうにベートーベンと同じく
あの もう間接的にやっと知るということなんですね
でも 本当に耳で音 音楽を聞こえる場合はそうじゃなくて
私たちにとってはすごいインパクト強く聞こえる
私が言うのはその状態
耳で見ることも 目で耳で聞くこと
目で見ることも 我々今この何か体を媒体として体を通して聞いてるんだから
それほどインパクト強いわけじゃないんです
今も だから今見る壁はなんかやっぱりいろいろ間接的に見ているんです
今聞く音も間接的に聞いているんです
耳を通して 神経を通して
脳細胞を通して いろんなことを通して聞かなくちゃいけない
それで本当に聞いてるかないかも結局わかる
だからベートーベンにベートーベンにどのように音楽が聞こえたかということはもうわからない
本人はわかってるかもしれませんだけどね
前はこのように聞こえた
今はこのように聞こえるんだとかね
で 私 普通の人間の状態っていうのは
この耳が聞こえなかったベートーベンの状態なんですね
聞こえる時の状態じゃないんです
そこでこの死ぬ瞬間でもう体は関係ないんですね
体が壊れているんですね
それで慰問が直接聞く
見る ですから その死ぬ瞬間の現象っていうのは
並の現象じゃないんで
ものすごい強力なインパクト
ですから 人 例えば誰か殴ったことがあると
私は悪い例しか出しませんからね
もう昔人を殴ったことがあったと
その時は人を殴った時でもいろいろ間接的なことだから
まあそれほど心にインパクトあるわけじゃないんですね
すぐ心からそれ消えたりもする可能性あるし
で 死ぬ時は臨死の時はそれ思い浮かぶ時はそうじゃないんです
あれとは違って ものすごくリアルに
徹底的にリアルに 直接に直接に心に映ってしまっちゃう
再現してしまう だからその時の心っていうのは強力にもうインパクトを受けている時なんです
看病している人にとってはさっぱりわからない
もう朦朧としていて もう終わりでしょうとね
というふうに思いますけど
本人がの心が普段の心よりすごい強力なんです
もう引っ越しの時だからね
こんなのんびりするわけにはいきませんね
その時は 引っ越しの瞬間だから
もうものすごい強力な勢いで荷物を片付いたり
もうラベリングしたり貼ったり
車に入れたりとかね ですから
そういう状態だからね
すごい心が回転するんです
次にはマルナサーナ・ヴィーティ
書いてなかった そこでこのヴィーティっていうのは
この心の流れですね 心の流れ
あの あのディエンネと同じく
このあるセットセットで仏教で考えているんですね
一個一個ではなくて 一つのものを見るということは
心の十七のセットなんですね
ばっかりいつでも十七あるわけじゃないんだけど
一応十七単位でカットしている
異門の場合はもっと短い
まあ八か九かどっちかの十回
十回かどちらの短い あのサイクルでカットしているんです
セットで ですから 認識一行に心はどれぐらいセットとして実況十七ぐらい
ありますね 眼耳鼻舌身の場合は
異門の場合は十七は必要ないんです
色声身七つだけ必要ですけど
まあそこら辺もう話終わってましたからね
ですから 認識の基本の基本ユニットは心いくつかのセットで認識するためには
目で物を見るためには
やっぱり見ること説明するためには
やっぱり心は十七項のセットが必要なんですね
一番明確に説明 場合は 十七項から十四
十五 十三ぐらいのその辺で一応目で見られると
耳でもそれぐらいのセットで聞こえると
心のセット セットたくさんあって
認識セット この認識セット一つはもうヴィーティですか
チッタヴィーティと言うんですね
日本語で何と言いますかね
そういうことで 生きている人の場合はずっとこの認識の心の流れをね
セット一つ一つ一つ一つと生まれて生まれていっちゃうんですね
一つのセット生まれたら一つの認識する
次に聞く場合は また聞くセットが現れる
見る場合は見るセットが現れる
考える場合は考えるセットが現れる
そういう風にセットセットでの流れなんですね
ですから このその流れの中で最後の字
最後のセット 最後の心のセットが死ぬことなんですね
ここでいうのは 最後の心のこの流れのセットが終わって死ぬ場合もあるし
いわゆる最後のジャワナ
即行心で終わるんでしょうし
即行心は全部終わったら七つも終わって次に死ぬ
新しいセットは生まれなくなっちゃう場合もあるし
セットの途中で切れる場合もあるし
まあ それほど難しいことではないですからね
そこでこの最後の心のセットが出てきて
そこでこの死ぬ心が生まれると
死ぬ心で言ったっても
これを有分心であって
別にまあそんな大胆なことじゃないんです
で そこで心の流れが終わると
別に死ぬ心って心が全然ないんです
だから本当はアビダンマでは死というのは定義不可能なんです
死はないんです 死はあるというと
もう瞬間の死なんですね
それはもう目を ま まぶたを閉じる時でも
瞬間の死はもう何百 何百万回も現れちゃうし
ですから この私たちって大げさ
大騒ぎにしている 大げさにしている死っていうのはアビダンマでは成り立ってないんです
私たちは人は死ぬでしょう
これ大変でしょうと で
この心の流れから見ると
最後の認識しようということを始まるでしょうに
それで最後のことを認識して終わって
それで終わりと その終わり心に死んだということを言うんですね
終わる瞬間で生まれる心は何というかというと
この一つのセットと一つのセットのつながりが作る有分心
いわゆる我々は生まれた時の同じ似ている心
生まれた時と同じ似ている心はいつでも認識と認識の間に生まれますからね
で その有分心がまた一個生まれるんですね
この一個生まれたらそれっきりで
その体にこの心が動かない
だから引っ越しすると同じなんですね
自分がもう引っ越し もう出て行くアパートのドア閉めて鍵をかけると
まあそれっきりそれで終わり
またそのアパートには戻れません
一旦戻りたくたって戻れませんしね
もうそれっきりでもう契約終わってるんだから
そんな感じで この心の中で
例えば我々は自分住んでるアパートの鍵かけるということは
そんなに珍しいことですかね
ドア閉めると 全然普通なことでしょうに
1 日何回もそれやってるんだから
それで 7月30日でもう契約終わるというと
我々はやっぱりもう 31 日目からか
あるいは 8月の 1 日からか
他のアパートに引っ越しするし
そこで 30日目もまあ鍵をかける
その鍵をかけることは全く普通な行為なんです
毎日やっていたことなんですね
でもその時の違うところは
そこで鍵をかけてところからもう二度とそのアパートに入れませんし
入る権利もなくなっちゃうし
その鍵も使わないし それで新しいアパートの新しい住居の新しい鍵でそれを開ける
そこを開けた瞬間からそこに住んでる限り
あの鍵で開けたり閉めたりする
でも鍵は鍵なんですけど
こちらの鍵とあちらの鍵が違うんです
それで心がここで最後に有分身生まれることは
もうこの体で最後の鍵をかけたことと同じなんですね
その瞬間で次の心が生まれる
間がない この間がないということだけをテーラワーダ仏教ではすごい厳密に言おうとしている
なぜならば宗派の教えが違いますからね
中有は他の仏教で認めているし
初期仏教とテーラワーダでは認めてないんですね
中有がないんだと 人が死んでまた生まれるとも
なんで真ん中が必要ですかと
でありえないんだ そんなことは
そういうことで アビダンマではすごく努力しているのは
この中有の概念なしに
とにかく輪廻転生を説明しようではないかと
ですから 今も私の心で瞬間心が現れて
消える瞬間で次の心が生まれる
間がないんですね 今も間隔なしに心が生まれ変わっていくんだから
死んだ瞬間でも間隔なしに次の心が現れると
それで終わりと 終わりではなくて
それで輪廻転生しているんですね
次の心 だからこの体の最後の心は
この体の有分身なんですね
有分身は ったら 次 次の心が生まれる
でもこの体ではなくて違う場所なんですね
違う場所 違う次元 この違う場所
違う次元が心が決める
あの臨終の時は自分が何を強力に考えてみたりしたんですかということによって
その勢いで次の心が次の次元が決めてしまっちゃうんですね
で 新しい場所に生まれるということは
もうその新しい場所で心がまた活動し始める
そこで最後の最初の心に正起心という
ただ名前だけ 大したことない
この正起心にも有分身とも言う
そこで新しい場所の有分身は古い場所の有分身とは違うんです
それは新しいアパートの鍵と古いアパートの鍵は違うんですからね
新しいアパートにいる限り
あの鍵を使わなくちゃいけない
新しい鍵を 引っ越しするとその鍵まで捨てちゃう
有分身っていうのは この鍵と同じことで
あのこの認識するためにいつでもスタートする時点なんですね
まあこちらはまあものすごい説明ありますけどね
あのタンハーヌセムーラケーナサンカーレーナジャニーマーナン
サンパユッテーヒパリッガイヒマーナン
サージャーターナンアディッターナバー
ものすごく難しくわかりにくく書いてますけどね
そんなに難しいわかりにくいことではないんです
ここで言いたがっているのは
なんで輪廻転生するかっていうことだけのことで
なんで輪廻転生するかというと
やっぱり欲でしょう 執着でしょう
別に だったらそれだけのこと
心が弱いでしょうし 例えば何かね
我々は突然なんか変な音を聞いたとすると
その対象が違う対象が入ったんだから
すぐ心にそれ引っかかっちゃう
引っかかってどんな音だろうとかね
あれはおそらく車の事故でしょうとかね
誰か怪我しただろうとか思ったりする可能性あるでしょうし
例えばこちらで勉強やってますけど
家に誰かがあの病人がいるんだと
子供が熱出していたんだとすると
そうするとどうしてもそれを思い浮かんだりする
なぜかというと ただの欲ですね
別に 執着でしょうね その対象に執着あるんだから
瞬時に心綺麗にすることはできない
智慧がある人だったら
今はここにここに座ってるんだから
今の瞬間しか命がないんだから
今の瞬間のことを見ていられることできますけど
智慧がない人には今の瞬間にいることはできないんです
やっぱりどうなったんでしょうとかね
心配しちゃうんですね
それは輪廻転生の原因なんです
その不可思議なものじゃないんです
それ何でもいいんです
ちょっと体の調子が悪いと私も同じですけど
それに心がすぐすぐ行っちゃって
勉強に行かないと で それで心のエネルギーはね
弱くなりますけどね そういうふうなことで
何か心に引っかかることあると
心はそこで回転する 死ぬ瞬間で何か頭に浮んじゃうでしょうし
浮かんだものから頭を離れない
認識が離れません 認識が離れませんだから体から心が終わっても
次の場所でまた同じ似ている波動の死んだ時の波動に全く似ている波動の回転が始まります
人は努力しないと 心っていうのは堕落する傾向だから
貪瞋痴に侵されてて堕落する傾向だから
何もしないで ただもう食べては寝てる寝るような生活しちゃうと
まあ来世は良くない ちょっとレベル低くなるんですね
餓鬼道とかね 行って幽霊になったりとかね
もういちいちあっちこっちとかね
そういうふうになっちゃうんですね
ただ そういう人々っていうのは
まあ仕事をしてご飯食べては寝る
食べては寝る それだけの寿命ことだからね
で 貪瞋痴をいくらか抑えようとかね
人々を助けてあげよう
いいことをしようというふうな精神的な努力をすると
そのインパクトは結構効くんですね
自分が一応自分なりにいろんないいことをしましたということを心に入りますから
そのそのわけで ほんのちょっと死ぬ時はちょっとレベル高い次元に行けるんですね
人間の場合は 人間よりレベル高い次元と言えば天国なんですね
ですから ほんの少々心のレベルが高くしておけば
普通の人間よりもちょっといいことを考えたり
いいことをしたり いい考え方を持ったりしちゃうと
それだけのことで天界には生まれ変わります
それいとも簡単なんですけど
死んでから天国に行くっていうことは
じゃあ人間やってますか？というとそうじゃないんで
人間の考え方を見ると
あくまでも人間の次元の中で何を食うか
どう食うべきかという
そういうもう食うことや何を見るか
何をして遊ぶかというね
まあそれをことしか何もないんですね
家のことやら家族のことやらと
もうもう何て言いますか
夜は何を作るかとかね
それ人間の次元はなかなか超えないんで
死っていうことは考えてもないんだからいけないんですね
簡単に行ける天国にも
天界に生まれ変わることはもういとも簡単なんです
でも いろんな人々をね
付き合ってさ 話してね
性格を見てみると もう徹底的にこの動物と同じく
この 1日の餌を探すことと
どこで何を食べて どこで寝るかと
食べてから何をするかと
それぐらいのところしか改善してないんですね
だから人間の次元は全然乗り越えられなくなっちゃうし
死ぬ時はどうせ育てれないんだから低次元に行っちゃうんです
そういうわけで 大勢の人々は死んだら低次元の苦しみのところにいてしまっちゃうんです
本当にバカバカらしいんです
このシステムを知ってると腹が立つほどバカバカらしい
人間何やってるんですかね
犬で猫でいいんですか？その言葉さえ私はわざと言んだけど
一般的に説法すると そんなこと言っちゃったら
もう暴走のもう何て言いますか
ご飯なし状態になっちゃうんですね
もう食えないんだと あんたにはお布施あげませんと
褒め称えてもう褒め殺ししなくちゃいけないんですね
それでさらに低次元に落ちちゃうんです
ですから この気がついてほしいということ
人間っていうのはもうすごいことをやってるつもりなんですけど
やってることは普通の動物やってることと同じで
動物たちは自分の次元を全く乗り越えられないでしょうに
人間にもそれは全く乗り越えられないんですね
今日何を食べようかなとか
どこで食べようかなとかね
明日何しようかなとかね
何時に起きようかなとかね
それぐらいの思考ですから
それで仏教の例えで言えばね
この大きな湖のそばにきれいな水がある
十和田湖とかね 富士山の周りにある湖とかね
いろいろすごい水がきれいです
ものすごい澄んでいて
そこのそばにいるんだけど
喉が渇いたなとかね 水があったら飲みたいなとかね
悩んでるんです 目の前にいっぱい水があるんです
飲めばいいのに飲まないんですね
あるいは気づいてない
自分がちょっと苦しいんだけど
喉が渇いてるんだけど
これ水を飲めば治りますよと
水を飲んだらすごい気持ちいいですよっていうことに気づかないんですね
それぐらいバカバカらしいことなんですね
人間天国に行かないのは
だからこの他の宗教やったっても天国には行けます
まあいい神にはなりませんだけど
天国に行ったってもバカはバカですけどね
でも世の中にはいるでしょうね
もう大変財産に恵まれてるんだけど
大バカもんたちでね で
あの 例えば宗教なんかで何やってるかというと
やっぱりなんとかこの高い次元のこととかね
もっと違う世界 人間の普段日常生活と違うことを
もっといいことに もう徹底的に教えて教えて教えて教えて
もうちょっと頭をね 上げてもらう
毎日曜日賛美歌を歌ったり
教会に行ってメサイアやったりとかね
お祈りしたりとかね 参詣をしたりとかね
そこでもう人間の次元と違う世界のことを何かを認識する
認識して忘れないようにする
自分が普通の人間よりは
まあいくらか まあマシな生活をしましたと
という気持ちは作ってもらう
そうするともう死んじゃったら
まあ天国に行くんです
ですから 天国に行くのは最も簡単に
あまりにも簡単だから面白くないと思いますけどね
これ面白いのは例えばね
まあこのサッカーのワールドカップのね
チケットを手に入ったとかね
言うとフランスに行くつもりはまるっきりなかったんだけど
せっかく入ったなら行ってみようかなということにはなるんですね
なぜならばみんなに買えるものじゃないしね
珍しいものだから もう誰にでもね
電車にのる 誰にでも乗れると言ったら
別にそれ大胆なことではないしね
家賃さえあればね もう誰にでも乗れますよということぐらいのことなんです
そういうことで 仏教の人々は天国に行ったっても
もうかなり気をつけないと
天界にいる連中はみんな仏教ってわけじゃないんです
頭がいいわけでもないんです
天国にいるもう連中も
すごくこの修行したりとかね
すごいいいことをして
もう素晴らしい人間の集まりっていうわけじゃないんです
ただ 人間よりはものすごいレベル高くて幸福に生きているだけで
性格はまあ もういろいろ
ですから 仏教の人々っていうのは天界に行っても気をつけなくちゃいけないというふうには思って覚えておかなくちゃいけないんですね
いわゆるこの心の流れ
心の働き 煩悩の働き そういうのは覚えておかないと意味がないんです
まあとにかく天界に行くっていうことはそんなもんで簡単なことだと覚えといてください
で この百六十九ページのこの
あの 慰問プリンス字という
あの心のセットの流れ書いてるんですね
で 可と書いているのはこの右文心ですね
道と書いているのは右文心で右文心が動くと
写と書いているってのは右文心が切れる
そこで終わるということ
バンクパッチで そこで慰問意識が生まれるんですね
その意識にこの自分を行った語
過去でした 語か何かを再現しちゃう
そのやったことを強烈に頭に浮かんでしまっちゃう
それで心が回転するんですね
即行心が生まれて で 即行心はこちらで五つと書いてあるんですね
大体最後のものだから七つは生まれないというふうな
考え方なんです 最後だからもう心弱くて
ですから五つぐらい即行心生まれたら
またあのインパクトのあるあの対象がまた残ってるんだから
花椒塩二つの心が生まれるんですね
それは熟心ですけど それで右文心が生まれるんですね
花椒塩二つぐらいの後で
その右文心は四心と書いているんですね
なぜ四心と書くかというと
もう最後の心だから この最後の右文心に次の
すぐ結晶心が生まれる
それも結局は右文心ですけどね
だから瞬時に生まれ変われることなんです
だからこちらでこの分けてますから
死までは現在で 結晶のところまだからは自由で次の生まれなんですね
間がないんです 生まれた瞬間
また右文心はたくさん生まれちゃうんですね
だからいつでも心のこの速度
あのちっちゃな一つ あの一節な一節一新設な
で 変化することを速度は変えませんと
そこで瞑想している人々は死ぬ時はどうなるかというと
あの 例えば色界の瞑想をしていると
瞑想対象としていろんな現象が現れるんですね
大体色界ではね もう何か
まあほとんど光ですけど
自分の瞑想によって何かの光が見えてくる
で それ強烈にインパクト強く見えてくると
で なんで強烈にインパクト強いかというと
異物が直接それを受け取ってるんだから
目で見る光はそんな強力じゃないんです
ベートーヴェン聴いた音楽と同じ強力じゃないんです
直接異物に映っちゃうとすごいインパクト強いんですね
そういう経験ある人々がね
まあ色界の瞑想の経験ある人々が
まあ死ぬ瞬間でも身体がガタガタたわれているんだから
どうせあの自分の瞑想体験が再現しちゃうんです
再現して そこを引っかかって次の生まれが色界の梵天に生まれるんですね
だからその禅定で作った心の次元
同じ波動 同じ波動の生まれ変わりがずっと続くということ
そこであの色界の禅定５つありますからね
差はこの心のレベルアップなんですね
第一禅定の場合は 一生懸命人は考えているんですね
だから第一禅定の場合はヴィパッサナーに入ることは可能なんです
頭ずっと考えているんだから
体の感覚もありますから
第二禅定の場合は ほとんど妄想という頭の働きがほとんど抑えているんだけど
やっぱり体の感覚とか
まあいくらかはそれでもあるんですね
言葉はそれほど邪魔してこないんです
第三禅定に入っちゃうと
言葉はもう消えちゃうんですね
言葉消えて それでも体の感覚あるんだけど
痛みとかなんとかはない
で そういうふうにこの言葉もなしに禅定状態にいられる
で 体の感覚はただ楽しい気持ちいい感覚だけしかないと
で それでこの第四禅定になると
また同じ感覚なんです
考えなくても考えることはないし
すごい楽しいという幸福だと
幸せだという感じに変わっちゃうんですね
楽しい感じが  第四禅定っていうのは
ベースに幸福 幸せという感覚は何もなく
ただ車の気持ちで 何のことない気持ちで
心のあの自分見ている瞑想対象がずっと続けてるぐらいの
この心のレベルアップなんですね
それはまあ訓練次第にササササッと育てることができます
で 無色界の場合はそれぞれちょっと違うんですね
対象がないんです 見える対象が
光とか ですから この禅定
色界の禅定までは簡単に育てられますけど
無色界に飛ぶということは
もうちょっとすごいエネルギーと修行が必要になっちゃうんですね
何も対象なしに あの空ですか
空を認識する 虚空というかね
何もない状態を認識する
そこで光を見た人と同じ経験なんですけど
体は感じないし 体も音は何も聞こえないし
ただ自分が空ということと一体になっていると
そういうふうに色界の禅定はつあります
そういう経験がある人が練習の時には自動的にそういう対象が見えてくる
見えてきて その次元で生まれ変わっちゃうんです
瞑想は壊れてない限り
壊れてしまったらもう現れませんだけど
壊れたってまた瞑想するとすぐまたその対象が現れます
で そういうふうなことで心が
死んじゃったら次の心が生まれる
その法則はずっと変わらないんだと
それは輪廻と思うんですね
この物体が死ぬか死なないか
そんな全然もう無関心で
体という物体 体という物体はゆっくりゆっくり出てきて大きくなるもので
それでその中で心活動して物体捨てられたらそれで壊れていっちゃうし
また他のところでゆっくりゆっくりと新しい体が現れるんであって
で それは我々俗人たちが
世の中の人々がすごい興味ある輪廻転生なんです
生まれ変わりなんですね
どんな体にするかと 仏教はどんな体になるかということは全然あまり興味ないというか
心の流れが輪廻転生だと
ですから人間 この世間
俗世間の中でこの輪廻転生を信じますとか
輪廻はもうもう私はあの人は死んでこういうところで今生まれてるんだというふうに